the issue in Palestine in Israel is that
there is a society that does not give
equal rights to one group of the
population and is that simple it's a
human rights issue and in the same way
that we were outraged at the apartheid
government in South Africa and any
injustice that we see anywhere in the
world we need to look at this critically
and see that the reality is the only
reason I'm even allowed to go to Israel
is because I have an American passport
and I'm lucky enough to have an American
passport because my grandfather came
here in 1911 and then or whatever year
and went back to Palestine and that's
how my father was able to come here if I
didn't have an American passport I don't
know if I would be allowed to travel to
the country where my father was born and
his ancestors come from so that right
there is strange and I mean without
getting into the specific nitty-gritty
of how they divide the land and have a
law's work the simple fact is it's not
about Arabs hating Jews and Jews hating
Arabs and Muslims hating Jews and Jews
hating Muslims it's about the struggle
for equality and human rights that's it
that's what it's about what the solution
is I'm not really sure I have I have a
personal belief that people should be
able to live in one secular state and
believe what they believe and be who
they want to be that's tricky
a lot of Israelis and Jewish people see
that as a problem because then there's
no Jewish state but um I don't know the
solution really but I do know that the
first step is acknowledging the
inequality and focusing on that and
really and really approaching the issue
as okay how can we make a government
that gives equal rights whatever you
call the country whatever you want to do
how can we make sure that someone who's
Palestinian or is allowed to travel from
point A to point B without having to go
through three thousand and
chat points just because they happen to
be born Muslim and Palestinian or
whatever the case I but I'm also
frustrated as I said that it's become
about religion it's not about first of
all what the other thing that I hate is
it's been going on for centuries because
it hasn't and I think it's really
important that one of the most important
things to me and in this play to do was
to first of all talk about the Middle
East that my parents both grew up in
which was pre 1948 where in Lebanon
there were Lebanese Christians there
were Lebanese Muslims and there were
Lebanese Jews then after world war ii
and the establishment of the state of
israel those people left the jewish
lebanese and they went a lot of them
went to israel a lot of them felt
uncomfortable that's totally
understandable but what happened was not
that i mean a lot of what happened was
in europe there was a world war ii there
were Nazis there was a lot going on the
english had a lot to do with why
palestine became Israel and I think that
the saddest thing that we can do is say
it doesn't have anything to do with me
I'm American I'm not Jewish I'm not Arab
same with Europeans Europeans should not
be like oh the Americans are responsible
for fixing and it's not our problem the
Europeans are a large part of why there
is a problem so the the first
misunderstanding is just that that no
one the Arabs
actually it's a the Arabs were probably
the only people at the time who were not
cruel to Jews or anti-semitic at the
time of you know Hitler and world war ii
they Jews lived in the Arab countries
and then the State of Israel was founded
and then all of this trouble began so it
the first thing that really gets me at
that when people say it's been going on
for centuries since the Bible since the
Bible it's not the reality this is a
modern political phenomenon that we need
to all
look at and see and see the realities of
what is going on and why it's going on
and and so I think that for me I find it
really frustrating when people say that
it's not just an issue for Palestinians
and Lebanese and Syrians and Iraqis to
care about I mean or even just American
Jews
everyone should care everyone should
know because we're all sort of complicit
in it and it's not about you know liking
one person better than another or you
know if you if you support Palestinians
that doesn't mean that you are denying
the Holocaust or saying that Jewish
people have not been persecuted they're
there there's there's much more
complexity in the issue and and I think
that I really wish that we could all
sort of mm-hmm
get through thee I mean I don't know how
it's gonna be done to be honest view and
I think on both sides I don't know how
you stop I do know that there are human
interactions 1 on 1 or 2 on 2 or like a
small group of people they come together
and they let's say Palestine is Israelis
they come together and they speak and
maybe they don't disagree on it they
don't agree on everything but they find
a human connection but for some reason
I'm the larger level we can't recreate
that and I find that overwhelming and
frustrating
well my dad passed away a lot of people
were like why did you bury him in
Lebanon in a Quaker Cemetery because we
buried him in my mom's village which is
a Christian Lebanese village and so
people who know enough about Middle East
politics are like well Lebanese
Christians don't like Palestinians you
know right there is another so why was
he buried there he should have been
buried at Palestine your father was the
symbol of Palestine
the funny thing is my father lived in
Palestine until he was about 11 and even
within that time he was back and forth
to Egypt and then after that he was in
Egypt and then he came to America at 14
and has been had been here ever since
until he died so 50 years in America um
more than that so and he was born with
an American passport too so
Palestine the place it's not that my
father was fighting we went to visit his
house but he didn't want to go inside my
father did not want to move into his
house and get it back and say this is my
house and my land my father just felt
that as a Palestinian in America who had
become he had when he started speaking
out about Palestinians yet has achieved
some success in his field which was
comparative literature and literary
criticism and he felt that he had a
voice and that he it was important that
he say something about what he knew to
be the reality of the situation which
was these people are not being treated
fairly in any way this is not it you
know at the time you know Israel is not
a democracy these people are not given
rights and it's my duty as a Palestinian
to to say that to you and be the voice
of people who can't speak for themselves
so he took that on and it became you
can't really help if people start to
idolize you or decide I mean you can't
control you can to a certain degree but
you can't really control if people start
seeing you as like the MIT the son of
Palestine you know and to this day
people say I didn't realize you weren't
Maz
and I'm like why does it matter you know
and I mean Arabs say that because they
want my father to represent something
specific for them so he's taken on this
people have given him this this mantle
this you know he you know and my father
was not he would did not walk around
with a Arabic Athea and Arab scarf on
and he did not you know he wasn't a
revolutionary in that sense he he wrote
and he was a professor and he wore
western clothes and in for a very fancy
clothes that he got in England and he
didn't identify he identified more than
anything which I say as well and my mom
even says even though she lived most a
lot of her life in Lebanon if there was
any place we connect to it's New York so
my father didn't really feel like he
belonged anywhere or that Palestine was
a place he wanted to be but it was
purely an example of what a human rights
issue is it's a situation where people
are because of their ethnicity not given
the same rights as someone else and
that's why to him
the struggle for Palestine was a
struggle struggle for human rights it
was not a struggle for Muslims or
Christian or Jews and against Jews or
for it was simple and I think although I
still feel that my connection to
Palestine is tenuous and difficult to
figure out because I really don't feel a
connection to the place or the struggle
at times because it's become so
distorted at the same time I think it it
affects me deeply not just because my
ancestors are from there but because as
a human being who's sensitive he just
it's sad and it's not fair
that that people on both sides are
living in fear and sadness and hatred
when it it doesn't have to be that way I
think and I think one of the things I
always say is my dad was a really
sensitive person and I think a lot of
his reaction
to what he saw and and he knew was just
from a purely human sensitive point of
view like that's not fair and so that's
how I feel as well
there were you know things that I
definitely I don't necessarily disagree
with but I did I may not find as
important or or you know in
intellectually I'm speaking of
literature and such but what I tend to
do is one of the things about my dad
that was and he said this a lot he did
not want disciples he did not want
people to just agree with him there were
stories of you know students in his
class using jargon from comparative
literature and him being like that's not
your word that's fucose word choose your
own word you can he wanted people to
disagree with him as long as they had
their own ideas and their own thoughts
and that was always what was the most
important time it was never that people
follow him so that's been interesting
also in in terms of what I said before
about Palestinians and how they want him
to be this that my father's last wish he
did not ever want people to idolize him
and take what he said as gospel he
wanted people to constantly challenge
and constantly ask questions and
constantly so that that's the only thing
in terms of his work and his
intellectual legacy that frustrates me
which is that people when people dismiss
his ideas and say you know I don't agree
with him the lebra he would have said
fine but what do you believe and
encourage you to argue and I think that
people are mistaken and thinking that he
would have been like no I'm right I'm
right I'm right I'm right because he
wouldn't so that's the only thing in
that realm that actually annoys me a
little in terms of it I think his work
speaks for itself and I I say very
clearly I may be his daughter I may have
been influenced by him but I I can't
defend someone's body of work especially
if it has nothing to do with me
and I'm as I said open to people as he
was criticizing his work when I'm not
open to is nasty misinterpret
of him as a human being which i think is
really difficult especially in this day
and age with the internet and stuff
because people believe what they read
and a lot of people have opinions and
even when I did my plane they were like
oh I thought your dad was dead uh and
it's because they read it on Wikipedia
but I don't know who wrote that
someone's opinion of who he was and what
he did so I mean I think anyone's
Michael Jackson's kids can say this you
know it's hard when you have to see
nasty stuff written all over the place
because everyone has access to the
Internet now and everyone can voice
their opinion and it's frustrating that
people take what they read as fack